THE LEAD, 13 FOR ON THE OTHER
END.
>>@LOOTHTHE E REREBOBOUNUND D CH
BYBY E EMBMBIIIID.D.
EMEMBIBIIDID.
EUBANKS, TRYING TO PICK UP
ACHIEVE ONE THERE.
THE REFEREE:, NO
HE IS FEELING IT TONIGHT.
>> Alaa: EUBANKS AIN'T READY
FOR IT .  HE'S
THE LEAD
>> Alaa: WE HE HAD
POSSESSION, BUT STILL A CALL
HERE IN  --
>> Alaa: PRIME TIME.
>> Kate AND
JOEL, GOESFROM BEYOND
THE ARC, AND
>> JOEL WANTS IT ALL ARM ON THA
>> To PERHAPS PLAYING A
ROLE IN THAT.
NONETHELESS, RIGHT NOW,
BOTH,
OFFENSIVE.
PLUMLEE
>>Alaa: HE HAS GOT
AT TYRESE EVADING HEIGHT
ADVANTAGE.
THE LONG ARMS.
CURRY STAYING LOW, RUSSELL'S
SCREEN.
JOEL.
TWO ON THE SHOT CLOCK.
OFFICIALS.
HE IS STILLNIGHT FOR
EMBIID.
MINUTES TO PLAY IN BOSTON.OFFEN
IS OUT ON THE FLOOR OR THOUGHT
JOEL EMBI OFF-BALANCE SHOT TO T
OUTSIDE.
HOFINAL FOUR, AND
HE WAS MY POIN
ATTACKING THE RIM.
THIRD QUARTER.
JOEL, OFF THE BACK , DIRECTING
TYRESE KEEPS IT IN.ARE
CURRY IS GOING TO TAKE
THE SIXERS LAND FOR
THE HEAT TONIGHT.JALEN
SU
GG
S.
THE HEAT TONIGHT.JALEN
SU
GG
S.
THE HEAT TONIGHT.JALEN